-Hey, guys!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-Wow.
-We are so --
It's so great to see you.
You look fantastic.
Thanks for coming back.
-Thank you so much.
That was really nice, guys,
by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's such a buzz
around the whole block
in New York City,
just the fact that you're here.
We're so excited.
-Really? Aww.
-Well, yeah. We've got to talk
about "Midnights."
Congrats on this!
-Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I just want to break down
a couple of things.
In just one day of sales,
it became the top-selling album
of the year already.
Yeah, in just one day of sales.
Of the whole year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Midnights"
broke Spotify's record
for most streams in a day.
Today the top 10 songs
on Apple Music
and Spotify
are from "Midnights."
You can plug your ears because
I'm going to just keep going.
-No, I like it too much.
[ Laughter ]
-"Rolling Stone"
called "Midnights"
an instant classic
in their five-star review.
"Rolling Stone"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And right now, this album --
I know.
This album is on track to sell
well over one million
copies in its first week.
That is history, buddy.
Congratulations.
Unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- Yeah.
-How are you feeling?
Is it a lot?
Is it exciting?
Are you freaking?
-I'm beside myself really.
Yeah, it's actually --
It's a concept record,
but it's my first
directly autobiographical album
in a while.
Because the last album
that I put out
was a rerecord of my album
"Red," so that has some space.
You know, I wrote that stuff
a decade ago.
"Folklore" and "Evermore,"
I was -- It was like story time.
It was like mythology.
Like, I'm creating a character.
They went and did this
and felt this way.
So, I'm feeling like --
I'm feeling very overwhelmed
by the fans' love
for the record.
I'm also feeling, like,
very soft and fragile.
[ Laughter ]
So it's --
-It's everything.
-The two can exist at once.
But the fact that the fans
have done this --
like,
the breaking of the records
and the going out to the stores
and getting it.
It's like, you know, I'm 32.
So, we're considered
geriatric pop stars.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I don't think so.
-They start trying to put us
out to pasture at age 25.
I'm just happy to be here.
-No, no, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's so funny.
Oh, you're just getting
starting, buddy.
You're just getting started.
You said a lot of this album
is made out of 13 stories,
13 sleepless nights
throughout your life.
-Yeah.
-Is it tough --
I mean, I don't know
how you do it.
Do you just get up and go --
in the middle of your --
[ Laughter ]
Or, you know, record something
on your phone
or you jot something down.
Or like, "this is something,
I don't even know
if it's good --
I'm blurting it out."
Or you do go like,
"Oh, this has a good hook"?
-I kind of do all of that.
I love writing songs, poems,
stories, scripts.
I love writing those things
because there's a part of it
that I don't quite understand
how it comes to fruition.
There's something so mysterious
about writing.
But I found that the more --
the more I write,
the more I keep writing.
I don't know what's been
going on.
But in the last six
or seven years, I've just --
I've just been constantly
making things.
And the more things I make,
the happier I am.
-Yeah.
-So, I've just continued
to do it.
I'm just happy you guys
like that.
-No, we love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, yeah, some of them --
sometimes it feels
completely involuntary.
Sometimes, like, your day is
completely interrupted by a hook
or a lyric or just a thing
on piano or you know.
Sometimes you don't know what
the place for it is going to be.
But I just am always reaching
for my phone
and recording things.
-And do you know, like,
do you know "Mastermind"
was going to be the 13th track?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Wow.
That's meta.
That's meta right there.
That is so "Mastermind."
[ Laughter ]
-I think over the years
my fans and I,
we kind of have
a really funny sort of --
like, they tease me a lot.
And I enjoy it.
-You do, yeah.
-And one of the things --
[ Cheers and applause ]
One of the things they like
to make fun of me for
is the kind of cryptic needing
to plan things out.
And, like, I think we've
just stopped
pretending it's accidental
at this point.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that was fun.
Now it's part of --
-We've stopped.
-It's almost like you should
just write like five albums
just for one album.
'Cause you're like,
"No, this has to mean this,
and this has to --"
The way you listed
just the names
of the tracks was so exciting.
We were freaking out.
-Thank you for saying
that was exciting.
I was hoping people were like --
-I loved it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was so fun.
With the bingo balls
going around.
-Yeah, I posted videos
on TikTok of me
with a vintage bingo cage,
like with the handle.
And I just announced track --
you know, one at a time.
-And people, including me,
I go,
"Oh, I think that will be
my favorite song."
[ Laughter ]
Without even hearing the song.
-It's so cool to hear you say
that because that was just me,
you know, I don't know,
with my phone and a bingo cage.
-On this one, you collaborate
with some very fun people.
I saw Zoe Kravitz.
-Yeah.
-We love her.
-Yes.
-Lana Del Rey.
-Amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then I saw on drums --
is it Dylan O'Brien?
-Dylan O'Brien.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm sorry.
So, how -- Is he a drummer even?
-He is.
-Wow.
-And, you know,
not a lot of people know that.
-I did not know that.
-And now they do.
But I like -- I really --
I love to make things
with my friends.
I love to work with my friends.
I think that the experience
of making something
is just as important as how
proud you are of it in the end.
And I think it really informs
how proud I am of something
if I had a really joyful
experience making something.
This is a pretty dark album,
but I'd say I had more fun
making it than any album
I've ever made.
-Isn't that interesting?
-It's --
Because I don't think that art
and suffering have to
be holding hands all the time.
I think you can --
I think you can write songs
about pain or grief
or suffering or loss
or hard things
that you go through in life.
Shame, you know -- love to write
about that one.
[ Laughter ]
Self-loathing.
I could go on.
But I think,
you know, with time
and with the more albums
I put out,
making albums and making things
and writing things feels
like a way to sort of suck
the poison out of a snakebite.
-Yeah.
-You're just like --
-Get it out.
-You're putting it
in the music,
you're putting it in a song.
And it could be the most
harrowing song
you have ever heard,
but we had a blast making it.
-Good.
-And with "Snow on the Beach,"
which features
the genius Lana Del Rey --
-Yes.
[ Audience cheers ]
-Yeah, you should --
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, very lucky to have
collaborated with her on that.
And Dylan was actually
in the studio with me and Jack
because we were --
A lot of the time
we record at his place.
And Dylan was just hanging out,
like, drinking wine with us
and listening to stuff.
And he was just trying out
the drum kit there.
He wasn't -- He wasn't serious.
[ Laughter ]
But we -- But we were --
-That's how it happens.
-As I said,
we were drinking wine.
And so, we were just sort of
like, "Oh, we haven't recorded
the drums for this one yet,
see if you wanna --"
And he just played the drums
on the song.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
Sometimes it's --
it just happens like that.
-But did you know him before
the film "All Too Well"?
-So, no, I didn't.
I reached out to him to be
in the short film
for "All Too Well"
because I had always
really loved his work.
I also felt like he seemed like
a very quick-witted person.
And I knew that --
-He's funny.
-I wanted the character
to be charming.
I wanted -- I wanted that sort
of charming, quick, cleverness
and the charisma to be
why we love the character
because there's a lot
of complexity to that character
that makes us
not love him as much.
So I wanted Dylan
to bring something...
-His layers. His -- Yeah.
-...to the character
to make us, you know, love him.
And I do think that was achieved
in the short film.
Meanwhile, I mean, Dylan and I
become really close friends.
Jack becomes really
close friends with Dylan.
We all start hanging out
all the time.
Like, it's the same with
Sadie Sink, who was in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just --
I've been very lucky
to work with
really nice,
really talented people.
And that's not something
I ever take for granted.
And a lot of the time,
we end up really good friends.
-But is it because --
I mean, you've --
you've done the albums,
you've done the rerecordings.
But also, you haven't toured in
like four years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-We want you to.
-I think I should do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are we talking sooner
than later?
-You know, I should do it.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When it's time,
you'll let us know.
-When it's time, we'll do it.
[ Laughter ]
I miss it.
I really miss it.
I miss, you know,
when you write songs
and you're proud
of the songs,
and you have the fans reacting,
the most potent way
that you can see them react
is when you're looking
into their faces.
Do you know what I mean?
I miss that a lot.
I really miss that connection.
-They're looking at you
right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-So, it's like --
I'm thinking something like,
it's like this but with singing.
-Yeah, okay, good.
By the way, I saw you received
a doctorate from NYU,
and you had
a very great speech.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're a doctor.
Dr. Taylor Swift.
Sorry, I should have announced
you earlier as doctor.
-No, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
I respond to many things.
-I'm sorry.
I'm just getting used to it,
yeah.
And you said --
You made a funny joke.
You're like, "I'm a doctor,
but I'm not the doctor you need
in case of an emergency.
Do not call me.
But you call me if you need
me to name breeds of cats."
-Yeah.
-"I could be a doctor at that."
And you said,
"I could name like,"
I don't know, 50 breeds of cats
or something like that.
-Yeah, that was me committing
an act
of extreme hyperbole
with the 50 --
I think I was like, "I can name
50 cats in five seconds."
I was trying to make a joke.
I don't think I can
actually do that.
-Well, we were actually
thinking, can you name --
see how many cats you can name
in 30 seconds and just do it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, we have the time, right?
We have a clock.
-You -- Uh...
-Yeah, let's -- Yeah, yeah.
Let's do it.
-Let's see how many cat
breeds you can name...
-Too late to back out.
-...in 30 seconds.
Taylor Swift.
-When?
When do we start --
No, don't start it now.
-No, no, don't start. Stop.
Stop!
-You have to say go!
Sorry! I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
This is really serious.
-Yeah, it really was.
-Okay.
You have to say --
When you say go.
-When I say go.
You already have your first one?
-Yeah.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
On your mark, get set, go.
-Scottish Fold.
Ragdoll. Ragamuffin.
Maine Coon.
British Shorthair.
Exotic Shorthair.
American Shorthair.
Devon Rex.
Cornish Rex.
Sphynx cat.
Abyssinian.
Persian.
Siberian.
Burmese.
Norwegian Forest cat.
Ocicat. Bengal.
Bombay cat. Russian Blue.
Is there a British Blue?
Munchkin cat.
A black cat.
A calico cat.
A cat that knocks pens
off of desks!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Dinging ]
That's how you do it!
More with Taylor Swift
when we come back.
Come on back, everybody!